I am guilty of overusing
the word brilliant.
It diminishes its value.
However,
if there was one person walking the
earth today who is truly brilliant,
it is Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson.
It would not be a stretch
to assume history.
We'll lump him in with soccer days,
Freud and young.
If you haven't yet gone
down the JBP rabbit hole,
you may think I'm being hyperbolic,
but I assure you everything
you've heard is true.
He is a cultural icon,
a phenomenon,
and possibly one of the
smartest people alive today.
Formerly a Harvard professor,
Jordan Peterson is currently a clinical
psychologist and professor at University
of Toronto and has become a
celebrity in his own right,
which is a very,
very good thing for all of us as many
in academia and the left seek to make
victims of anyone who isn't a white CIS
gendered male providing safe spaces on
campus as so young adults never have
to experience the horrors of being
offended.
Dr. Peterson has been speaking about the
assault on the greatest liberal value
of all free speech.
You may have learned about him a couple
of years ago when he ignited controversy
by refusing to use the long list of made
up gender neutral pronouns that was put
into Canadian law.
Bill see 16 while he has no
objections to trans people,
he argued forced speech under the guise
of gender identity and gender expression
are too broad.
Are the propositions of radical social
constructionists and are being used to
bully opponents into submission.
He says,
free speech is not just another value.
It's the foundation of
Western civilization.
Well,
you may have just learned of Jordan
Peterson from his recent interview with a
British third wave feminist who tried
every way possible to cookie cut Peterson
as a misogynist.
The channel for interview in
England with British journalists.
Kathy Newman went viral and
now Dr Peterson's online
videos and there are many
are being binged Netflix style.
I warn you,
you won't be able to watch just one.
He just released his new book,
12 rules for life,
an antidote to chaos,
which has rocketed to the number one or
two depending upon the day on the Amazon
bestseller list.
Depends upon where that tabloid trash by.
Michael Wolff is today
along with his new book,
it seems Jordan Peterson is ubiquitous.
His name is on everyone's lips.
I attended an event the other night and
heard his name mentioned several times
throughout the evening
by different people.
I learned about Jordan Peterson sometime
back watching his interviews first on
Joe Rogan's podcast and subsequently on
the countless speeches and lectures he
has given all which can
be found on youtube.
In fact,
he has opened up his classes to the
world for free all on line watching his
lectures.
You feel enlightened and
amazed how he combines history,
psychology,
science,
sociology and philosophy into a very
enjoyable and learn it experience.
There's so much I can say about Jordan
Peterson and I don't want to sound like a
fan boy,
but it is truly an honor
to have him join us today.
Obviously I'm not the only fan.
As he has had over 100
million hits on Youtube.
We opened up questions to ricochet
members and we'll be asking you a few,
but like all good things,
there was never enough time.
So if we don't get to yours,
apologies,
but we hope to have Dr. Peterson
back on again down the road.
So without further ado,
pour yourself your favorite drink.
Sit back and enjoy the whiskey
politics interview with Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson.
First of all,
Dr. Peterson,
I want to thank you for joining us
at whiskey politics on ricochet.
It really is an honor to have you with us,
especially how busy you are right now.
Now Watch me try and get an hour's
worth of questions into 30 minutes.
You just let me know when you need
to get off and we'll wrap it up.
Okay,
sounds good.
All right.
Thank you.
So your name is everywhere right now.
There are those of us who've
been following you for some time,
but something happened
in the past few months.
I don't know if it's the Kathy
Newman interview that did it,
but everybody is talking
about Jordan Peterson.
You wrote in your book,
you are always surprised.
People respond positively to what you're
saying regardless or regarding the
seriousness of the subjects.
Why do you think people in the tens of
millions are drawn to your message right
now?
What are they hungry for?
I think they are hungering for,
for,
I think they're hungry for evidence
that the idea that their lives are
meaningful and worthwhile
is actually true.
And I do think it's true,
and I detailed that
extensively in my first book,
maps of meaning,
which is a very difficult book,
but then again in 12 rules for life.
I think that it's reasonable to make the
observation that life is very difficult
and rife with suffering and
tainted with malevolence.
But despite that there are in the world,
there are ways of being in the world
that are noble and worthwhile and that
ameliorates suffering and,
and malevolence and that it's worthwhile
to grow up and take your place in the
world as a responsible citizen.
And that the ideas of sovereign
individuality that have,
that underpin the west are great ideas
and correct and that we shouldn't lose
the.
And so I think that people are,
there's a whole in people's hearts the
same shape as that message and so we may
hear it.
They feel like a part of them that they
didn't know it was missing has been
replaced and so that's
what it looks like to me.
Now you referred a lot of,
many of our listeners have been following
you for some time and a lot of people
that just learning about you and you're
known for detailing how postmodernism is
today's form of Marxism.
Is this what you're referring to here
that people have had enough of the
postmodernist maybe cause they've
taken over learning institutions?
Our media and culture?
Well that's part of it.
I think it's,
there's a deeper Malays do though is
then we'd become unmoored from our
traditional foundations and the
foundations let's say of Judaeo Christian
culture.
We don't understand them
who probably never did,
but we acted demoed anyways before,
but we can't lose sight of that tradition
without falling apart in 15 different
ways.
I think the postmodern
way of falling apart,
it's just one of many,
but it's very toxic.
It divides us into tribes based
on our ethnicity or our gender,
our race,
and then sets us against one
another as oppressive versus victim.
And it's a very,
very pathological and dangerous narrative.
So,
and I think people know
that instinctively,
they don't want to descend
into tribal identities again,
but that means we needed it.
We needed an identity that is
super ordinance to the tribal.
There has to be something above that.
And I think the idea of the sovereign
individual is the right transcendent
representation.
And I think that people know that too,
because it's,
that message is everywhere in our culture,
even know it's not made
as explicit as it should.
We're explicit as often as it should.
Yeah.
You talk about individualism,
me,
your message comes from the perspective
of a classic liberal and individualism
is part of that.
Uh,
but the interesting thing,
you've not only been a student of Marxism,
communism and socialism,
I mean you really went deep into it.
Soviet gulags the rise of Nazi-ism and
the Holocaust and you always refer to the
Gulag archipelago that
the machine eats itself.
You relate today's postmodernist
to that same machine.
Well,
I think they're driven by the
same pathological ideology.
You can tell that by their emphasis on
the impressive versus victim narrative,
which is classic Marxism is
just give him new clothing.
You know,
it's not the bourgeoisie
versus the protests.
Proletariat,
it's the oppressed minority
versus the oppressive here.
Majority,
same basic idea and company,
not the demand for such
impossibilities as equality of outcome,
which is unbelievably dangerous idea.
It's the same ideology.
It's just dressed up in more
current clothing and it's,
it's,
it's going to lead to the same place,
so unless we want to go there,
which I wouldn't recommend since we've
already visited and founded unpleasant,
it seems to me that we should pick a
different path and dispense with the
identity politics both on the left and
on the right and go back to what we got
right.
The thing that makes me a little
different than the classic liberal,
I guess in some senses
that there's probably more
emphasis from the liberal land
on individual freedom.
Whereas I put a tremendous amount of
emphasis on individual responsibility.
But the union between those two things
would be the emphasis on the individual.
No.
So in 12 rules for life,
a lot of what I'm trying
to inform people off,
let's say,
is that they can take on very heavy
responsibility for life in all of its
tragedy and let's malevolence and prevail
and that that's what they should do.
And that's the right way
to set the world straight.
It's the honorable way.
It's the noble way.
And it works too.
It's not,
it's not naive optimism.
I'm not a naive optimist.
I know how terrible the world is,
but I still think that we can,
we can live in it like admirable beings
and we can make it much better than it
is now.
We can start with ourselves and I
think that's the right path forward.
Yeah.
And I,
and I want to get into 12 rules of
life and they edit out to chaos,
um,
in a,
in a moment.
It's a fantastic book.
And,
and as of right now,
today,
it's number two on the
Amazon bestseller list.
So congratulations on that.
But it sounds like you've,
you've,
and what I've read here,
you've surrounded yourself,
uh,
with,
with understanding this
to the point where,
and I was a little surprised,
um,
you know,
Norman Doidge,
he wrote the forward in your book 12
rules of life and he says that you have an
expansive art collection of socialist
realist paintings of Lenin and early
communists.
He explains it so that you never forget
the hundreds of millions of people who
were murdered in the name of Utopia.
What about this ideology,
this horror,
if you will,
of human suffering that
steered you into studying it?
No,
it seemed to me when
I started studying it,
the 1980s,
we were still in the midst of the CEW
award and hosted a genuine threat not only
to the lives of every
individual on the planet,
but too well,
but to life itself.
And it seemed to me that there was no
problem that required solving more urgent
urgently then the problem of pathological
group identification and the conflict
that emerges out of it.
And the more,
I mean I,
I took,
I took what happened in Nazi Germany
and did in the Soviet Union and malice
China with deep
seriousness considering it,
what would you call it,
up a sign of the illness
that be set all of humanity,
not just those countries and
believe that there was no problem.
That was more,
it was more necessary to take
seriously and to try to solve.
And so that's guided me since probably
since the late 1970s I've put all my
effort and teaching pretty much into
understanding group identification at a
psychological level,
trying to account for the ideological
possession and then trying to figure out a
way through it so that people were
neither nihilistic nor puppets of right or
left wing ideology trying to find
out what the alternative to that was.
And I think that
responsible individuality,
you know,
with respect for society
and the group is the right,
I think we got the answer right in the
west and I think that's why the West
isn't complete hell.
Like so many countries are so many places.
Are you concerned this wave
authoritarianism is sweeping
across North America?
I mean we see it in the schools.
You became famous obviously
because of the Toronto,
uh,
University of Toronto
was situation with a,
with the law for the transgender usage
of words that you were forced to have to
say.
Uh,
I mean,
do the college administrators,
many of them who went at academia when
they adverted the Vietnam war themselves,
does just the society just
wait for them to all die off?
What does this end,
well that's a good question.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't know what's going to happen with
the universities because the humanities
are completely dominated by
postmodern radical left cause it's,
I mean the documentation
for that is clear.
Um,
I think what will happen is they'll
just run out of the audience.
That's what I'm hoping will happen is
that people will wake up and think,
oh Jesus,
this isn't education.
This is indoctrination and this is a
pessimistic and pathological view of the
world.
All we'll do is produce
increasing division and
hatred between groups and we'd
go better things to do.
So I'm hoping that people will turn
away from those disciplines in those
courses.
The problem is they often don't know
that that's what they're going to be
exposed to.
But you know,
who has Lincoln said you can fool
all of the people some of the time,
but you can't fool all of
the people all of the time.
Right.
So can I hope,
I'm hoping that people are waking up and
if they can find something better to do
with their lives than to
become chronically resentful,
professional protesters and
and instigators of group
conflict under the name of
some kind of compassionate morality.
It's complete.
It's completely reprehensible
as far as I can tell.
There's nothing in it's good.
Now it isn't to say that there's nothing
to be said on the left side of the
political spectrum.
Like I know full well that inequality
tends to grow and then as it grows,
it threatens the structure of society.
There has to be a voice for people
who are on the dispossessed end of the
distribution.
And so I think there's a perfectly
reasonable place for an informed left wing
who basically speaks for those who have
not managed to be or who didn't have any
opportunity to be successful.
But that's not the same as dividing this
up into identity groups based on gender
and eternally playing
oppressive versus victim.
Right.
Our normal relations between human beings
is what you're referring to the left
now trying to mediate that or do
they want the state to mediate that?
What is their end game here?
Well,
I don't know.
The end game hypothetically is a state
where of radical equality of outcome.
Nowhere no one has any more of anything
than anyone else and also no less.
But that's a completely impossible goal.
That will never happen.
You know,
as I'm a sole pointed out,
if you give the state enough power
to legislate equality of outcome,
you've also given the state enough power
so that it is certain that it would
become a tyrant and I believe that.
But I think that there are
people in the ideological camps,
both on the right on the left,
but we're talking about
the left at the moment.
Who would be happy to see everything
burned down as long as those who were
successful were destroyed along with it.
So there's,
that certainly happened in,
in,
in the Communist countries
during the 20th century,
there was a tremendous underground sense
of resentment and hatred that motivated
the destruction of whole
classes of successful people.
Like the,
like the successful farmers,
the Kulaks that were all
killed in the 1920s so
who knows what the end game is,
what they say,
what it is fairly straight forwardly yeah,
it's the destruction,
the patriarchy.
Well,
that speaks for itself.
You know,
what are the greatest quotes
I've read from you is,
is human beings are born
with different capacities.
If they are free,
they are not equal and if they
are equal than they are not free.
I think that was
originally Milton Friedman.
Oh,
was it Milton?
He so,
yeah.
Cool.
Melty.
Okay.
I think it's,
it's,
it's definitely the case.
Well,
the problem with equality
of outcome arguments is well
across what dimension are
you going to ensure that no one has
any more friends than anyone else?
Well,
no one is going to have any more lovers
or no one has a bigger art collection or
no one's better at playing
music or has a larger library.
Where are you going to stop
with the demands for equality?
There's no stopping place and people
don't even want the same outcomes.
So it's
people are,
the thing about freedom is that
people are free to be different.
No,
you know,
the price we pay for that to some degree
is the inevitability of comparative
failure.
But the Marxists liked to
blame inequality on capitalism.
And that's the one of the biggest
technical mistakes they make because
inequality is the rule in
natural and social systems alike.
So the populations are distributed
equally in cities and mass is distributed
unequally in stars and trees are of
different heights in the rain forest,
all following the same inequality
distribution that characterizes,
say income or wealth.
In a,
in a human society,
the inequality problem is much deeper
than it can't be laid at the feet of
capitalism.
It's a foolish analysis,
but,
but inequality is still a problem
and it has to be dealt with.
So,
but the idea that it can be eradicated
in some permanent forum and that the cure
would be better than the
disease is naive at best,
willfully blind,
most certainly,
and malevolent in most cases.
It's mostly based on
resentment and jealousy,
especially in North America because the
typical person in North America is rich
beyond the wildest imaginings
of people a hundred years ago.
You know?
So even if you're relatively
poor in North America,
you have central heating,
you have running water,
you have computational technology that
puts $1 trillion worth of information
every moment at your fingertips.
You know,
you're,
we're so rich.
Yeah.
And people don't have to worry about
being torn apart by animals or freezing to
death or anything like that.
It's a big difference.
Yeah.
And it's very unlikely to.
So the other thing I've been trying to
point out is that we should try to muster
up a little bit of gratitude for it.
What are the biggest challenges men and
women both have is finding the perfect
gift for a man,
whether it's a significant other father,
son,
friend,
could be a coworker or your boss,
somebody you play golf with.
You know,
it's never easy to find that gift.
And many of us end up just getting a
gift card and it's quick and it's easy,
but it's also quite boring.
And now with Valentine's Day coming up,
yeah,
you know,
we all realize it's a
cheesy hallmark holiday,
but it doesn't mean that you have to
get that guy at cheesy hallmark gift.
The solution is [inaudible] dot com it's
the only place to find awesome gifts
that guys love.
Now it isn't some Cologne sampler or
cheesy mug man offers a curated gift
collection for every type of guy.
There's different collections for the
sports fanatic home chef and outdoorsman.
If you're interested in
cigars or whiskey or beer,
check out classics like the NFL barware
crate and the whiskey appreciation
crate,
or a fresh takes on
traditional Valentine's day
gifts like the jerky heart or
the Salami Bow k and
it always cracks me up.
It looks good.
It looks really yummy.
You know?
Imagine you're a mad opening
up a whole crate of Salami.
Go to man crates.com pick the perfect
gift and then wait for that magic to
happen.
See,
what's going to happen is that it's going
to be delivered literally in a crate,
hence the name,
and there's no way to open it unless
they use a crowbar which happens to be
included.
So part of that gift is just getting a
guy to get a box open with a crowbar cue.
The Tim Allen voice a voice,
they have thousands of five star reviews
and every gift comes with a complete
satisfaction guarantee.
So go to [inaudible] dot com slash
whiskey and you'll get 5% off.
They don't offer a discount anywhere else.
Get 5% off right now at [inaudible] dot
com slash whiskey man [inaudible] dot
com slash whiskey
I have a few questions for you
from ricochet members here.
Many of our ricochet members,
you pseudonyms.
So you might hear a couple
of funny sounding names here,
but the first one doesn't.
His name is Brian Watt,
and he asks,
what do you think of the current
pope and his apparent leaning?
Some might say anticapitalist
pro socialists,
perhaps postmodernist outlook on life.
Does he find the current
Catholic hierarchy helpful
or a hindrance and standing
up against the wave of postmodernist,
neo Marxist indoctrination and
propaganda throughout Western societies?
Okay.
I would say I probably don't know
enough to really answer that question
intelligently.
It's necessary generally speaking,
for the Catholic Church to err on the
side of compassion for the poor and
dispossessed so we could say,
well,
perhaps that's what the
current pope is doing,
but I don't know enough about his
doctrines and aims to provide a criticism
that's any more intelligent than that.
Okay.
A second one is from judge mental told
you he had some great pseudonyms here.
Judgemental asks you,
what do you think will
be the next battlefield?
We've gotten to the point where even
gender is now set to be up for grabs.
What does it go from here?
Hmm.
There'll be babbling over whether or not
scientific truth is acceptable as truth
or just another form of power,
power play power.
That's already happening.
Um,
there'll be in the soul to him the idea
of qualitative diff distinctions per se.
The idea that one thing
is better than another,
that'll come under attack and all sorts
of different dimensions that's already
happening.
Um,
because the problem is,
is that if you allow for
qualitative distinctions,
so if you allow for the suggestion
that one thing is better than another,
then you rationalize the
existence of inequality.
Because if one thing is
better than another and people
provide the better thing,
then you can make a case
that they should succeed,
where others should fail,
and that produces inequality.
So the radical argument against inequality
has to end in the destruction of the
idea of value distinctions themselves.
And I think that's part of,
that's built into postmodernism anyways.
That's the sacrifice
they're willing to make.
So we're going to see more of
an outright attack on biology,
especially evolutionary biology and
psychology that's already happening.
Um,
and assault on the idea that scientific
truth has some sort of privileged status
that's already happening.
So we'll see an assault on the idea that
there's any such thing as an objective
of education that's already
happening in Canada,
in Ontario with the elementary teachers,
federation has already decided that the
purpose of education from kindergarten
to grade eight is to produce students
with a social justice activist
orientation.
And they've even selected
all the literature that the
kids will be exposed to in
order to foster that
India logical perspective.
I mean,
that's right out in the open
and that's on their website.
It's part of the curriculum.
So,
so is this a devaluing of empirical
evidence then that we just don't believe
anything anymore?
We believe what the postmodern
ideas that you believe,
whatever fosters the
interest of your group.
There's no truth above that.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's an absolutely dismal hypothesis.
Wow.
Now,
as people were asking questions of you,
uh,
in a,
in our forum and interesting
discussion between ricochet members,
NFE and front seat cat occurred,
again,
pseudonyms occurred in,
in relation to your interview with Kathy
Newman and pertaining specifically to
agreeableness.
Now remember Anna fee told her sister
who was angry over not being paid as much
as a male coworker to go and make the
case to her boss and demand more money.
Now I know anesthesia is
a strong willed woman.
Now her sister felt her work should
speak for itself and front seat cat,
another member agreed with NFE sister
that she shouldn't have had to ask that
the raise was then about behavior
and not about the quality of work.
You referred to agreeableness,
right,
and not gender as the reason people
may not achieve their potential.
It's one of the reasons,
there's many reasons for pay differential,
but not only do you have to do good work,
you have to be seen to do good work
and you have to make a case for it.
It's like in the best
of all possible worlds.
He would sit back and your accomplishments
would speak for themselves.
But that assumes that the people that
you're talking to have enough time to even
pay attention to what
you're doing and notice.
And that's often not the case,
especially if if you're a quiet
worker and you're competent,
the price you pay for
that is in visibility.
And people,
you'd think,
well,
people should notice what we're,
what we're doing and rewarded
and they probably should.
But that doesn't mean that you lack
all responsibility in making your case
known.
And most of the time a boss,
a manager who's busy doing
150 different things,
isn't going to
be alert constantly enough to make sure
that your career is being fostered in
the optimal possible manner.
You might have to make a case.
Often people don't even know what
you're doing if you're competent.
And so I think it's a very
naive view of the world to say,
well,
my work should speak for itself.
It's like,
well,
the wouldn't be advertising if
people's work could speak for itself.
And there wouldn't be marketing,
there wouldn't be sales,
you know?
And for most products,
sales,
marketing and advertising
is like 75% of the product,
right?
So it's just naive and it's not
like money is just laying around.
Everyone's after it.
It's in scarce supply.
And so if you want to develop your career,
if you have some notion about
how much money you need to make,
then you have to go out there and,
and strategically employ
a plan to obtain that
and learning how to promote
yourself or stand up for yourself.
And you've referred to this in your book,
you're talking about standing up straight,
right?
I mean it's about having
confidence and belief in yourself.
Yeah.
Well if you lunch also,
I also tell people in the book suggest
to people that they consult the
resentments.
So let's say you're
working way madly at your job,
then you're very mouthy,
but less competent.
Coworker is getting paid more and it
just starts to eat away at your heart and
to poison your relationship
with your work.
Well,
what should you do about that?
No,
you should first of all notice that
you're becoming resentful and then you
should ask yourself,
well,
am I just being whiny and
neurotic and complaining?
Or is there an actually an injustice here?
And if the answer is there's
actually an injustice,
then you have to make your case and you,
you do that so that you stop yourself
from being resentful so that you can stay
happy to be going to work.
And so that you can set
the institution straight.
You know,
justice doesn't appear of its own accord.
It's something you have to
work for on your own behalf.
Comes on the behalf of others.
You know,
it's like the,
let's say you're a husband and you're
a little bit too agreeable and you say
your wife doesn't,
um,
there's things that you need or
want that your wife isn't providing.
You won't talk to her.
You say,
well,
if she really loved me,
she just know.
It's like,
no,
she's not omniscient and
you're not transparent.
So you have to go and say,
look,
here's what I want.
You have to negotiate about it because
maybe you don't get what you want.
But maybe you do,
here's what I want.
Here's what would satisfy me.
This is why it's important.
This is what we need to do.
And that's how you start the relationship
from becoming an anachronistic and
corrupt.
And it's the same at work.
You always have to fight for justice,
always,
always.
And why not?
Of course,
you have to
some of your critics after that interview,
which went viral,
it's insane.
Uh,
they refer to you some of the critics
and it's very few of them by the way,
that mostly in the media and academia
they refer to as a massage earnest.
Yet you say the greatest
threat to women is a weak man.
It seems.
Dr. Peterson,
we are surrounded by them today.
Are men becoming weaker?
Well,
men are constantly told that
if they were just harmless,
the world would be a much better place
if they were weakened few tile and you
know,
constrained older,
assertive and aggressive impulses
and quit going out there and being so
patriarchal and all of that.
And it's mostly nonsense mean when you
want for men is an extraordinary and
women as well as an extraordinarily
high level of competence.
And most of our functional
hierarchies are built on competence,
not power.
And why in the world would any woman want
not want to have a man around who was
competent and less.
All she wanted was dumb to be dominant,
you know?
And some of them would like
that because they're there,
they'd had their relationships with men
damaged and they want to make sure that
anybody that's around them is under
their thumb because they're afraid of,
while they're afraid of the alternative.
But it's not a good way to live.
And so this is how this whole,
this misogyny ideas just,
it's so absurd that it's,
it's,
it's evidence of something else.
I'm a reasonable person.
I don't approve of what the
radical leftists are up to.
I know why what they're doing is
pathological and where it's going to lead.
I make the case strongly and reasonably.
And because they have no
defense of their ideas,
what they do is target me
with all sorts of epithets.
Mean,
I've had dozens of women in my
clinical practice who I've been hell,
I've helped them develop
their careers like mad,
you know?
And a lot of these were
high achieving women,
but not all of them.
Some of them were struggling
along at the bottom.
We spend hours and hours all the time
out how to strategize so they could move
themselves forward in their relationships
and when they're in their careers,
in your education.
So the idea that I'm a misogynist,
it's like,
well,
whatever you,
you have your opinion about
it and you have your reasons.
But um,
the fact that I'm helping men develop
their competence hardly makes me an enemy
of women unless the woman who think that
are so clueless that they think that
they would benefit
by having more weak men in the world.
And some people think that,
but it's foolish.
Last question on that for,
I watched the followup
interview in Amsterdam.
I think it wasn't,
you obviously had decompressed
a bit from the interview,
which was shortly before that and you
said you felt somewhat bad that you did
the Gotcha moment further away from this.
You know,
a couple of weeks now in retrospect,
would you have said anything
differently in that interview with her?
Yeah.
Well,
I'm not unhappy with the interview
and the idea with the Garcia was,
I was making a joke,
you know,
and yeah,
it was a wild time joking.
There's,
there's utility in the Joel Comm.
One of my friends pointed out that I
could have used that as an opening to
starting a more detailed conversation,
a more serious conversation,
but we were pressed for time.
The interview was almost over.
It's useful to keep things to introduce
some liberty where that's possible.
Um,
I think the interview went as
well as I could have hoped.
Porn.
That's good enough.
Like,
you know,
going over it with a fine tooth comb.
I can think of things that I might've,
what broaches I might've taken.
It wouldn't be different,
but it isn't clear to me that
that would have necessarily been
better.
Does it surprise you they
turned her into her a victim?
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
it was actually quite shocking to me.
Yeah.
It can begin with because it was so,
it was so both predictable
and preposterous.
It's like,
well,
she's a public figure.
She's hardly a victim.
She's,
it's not like she's
without power or influence.
She's got plenty of it.
She's doing quite well financially too.
I imagine them on most,
on most dimensions of measurement.
Um,
but to try it out,
that victim narrative so rapidly was,
well,
first of all,
reprehensible and second of all,
appallingly predictable.
And it was quite shocking
because when it first happened,
about 20 newspapers carried,
picked up the ball and ran with it,
you know,
mostly in Canada and in the UK,
but then a counter narrative
develop pretty rapidly.
And,
uh,
you know,
it isn't clear that the victim narrative
is the one that carried the day.
So
I don't think it,
I don't think it carried the day,
but it was certainly voiced out there.
And you know what,
what do they say when you
have ink by the barrel?
They're going to be the loudest ones.
Yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
so,
uh,
last question.
Uh,
you're,
you're obviously a Canadian,
but you have your
pulse on American politics.
And Ricochet is a right of
center site and community.
In one of your speeches,
you thought the vote for Trump was people
basically just saying they had enough.
Were you surprised by the election?
Yeah,
a month before that I was certain
that Clinton was going to win.
I was shocked by the election.
But the thing is the
Americans that mean split 50,
50 for about 15 years.
So,
and it was really no different than that.
The split between the
population is so close that,
you know,
minor perturbations can
throw it one way or another.
And I do think that identity politics
was one of the factors that elected Trump
people had just had enough of it.
So I guess I was surprised because I
didn't regard Trump as a particularly
credible,
um,
potential leader.
And I,
you know,
it's not like I was
alone in that estimation,
but,
um,
I guess people,
I think people decided they preferred
the impulsive lies of Trump to the
calculated lies of Clinton.
You need more honest lies.
Wait,
what are your thoughts thus far?
Um,
I'm refraining from judging.
Look,
North Korea.
So look good for the good and
the world hasn't fallen apart.
So I'm always amazed
when not hasn't happened.
So hopefully that will continue.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's good.
Go.
I'm,
I've got another meeting coming up right
away and my people around here getting
all agitated because I'm talking,
we're not shape moving.
Some doctor talked to Jordan Peterson.
It's been a treat.
Talking with you today.
Would love to continue to discuss
this discussion with you soon.
Thank you so much for your time.
Yeah,
well thanks very much for the invitation
and it was good talking with you.
Thank you.
Take care.
All right.
Bye.